I used to be able to stop traffic quite
easily by just walking down the street
no matter said cuz I had long hair this
is my not really writing or performing
[Music]
and I was not a natural performer I
didn't feel at ease on-site ever
I wanted to define the archetype Messiah
Rockstar that's all I wanted to do
[Music]
I had to be very exaggerated in the
beginning to defy people to put me into
a category so that that would leave me
room to work I didn't quite stand up to
tell him in the beginning that we'd have
to have wear makeup and
Mick came from whole you know his very
down to earth as was the rest of the
spider you know
would you mean make up see when they
realized how many girls they could pull
when they look so otherworldly they took
to it like a fish toward
[Music]
the premise was menon from Mars I'm from
Bromley I'm just a bit different from
other men in that way you know and I
just saw the world in a bit another kind
of fashion
[Music]
[Music]
it's very hard to have relationships in
tun Dr Shindell drinking I was very
lucky that I found my way out of that
being working-class always would feel
that there's never enough to leave my
family
so I there's a kind of a survival
instinct and everybody will be okay
[Music]
[Music]
you